so the last couple of months I've been
thinking about the content on my channel
specifically the content that people
prefer to watch here's a list of the
most watched videos on my channel over
the last 30 days one thing that they all
have in common is that they're about
dark morbid science topics
it's no secret that these kinds of
videos are more attention grabbing and I
totally get that however I'd always hope
that people who watch these types of
videos would also watch more sciency
videos the reality is that's not the
case here are the views on my more
sciency videos for the last 30 days
yeah pretty low the data is very clear
and it's that people want to see more of
the Macabre and darker science videos
which by the way I have no problem with
I enjoy making both types of content
however as far as transparency goes if
I'm going to dedicate my channel to a
particular type of content I believe the
channel name and brand should reflect it
as well as of today questions for
science will be renamed to dark science
with this change you'll see less of
these videos and more videos like these
now for a quick question and answer
segment am I leaving this channel no
will I be deleting this channel no will
I be starting a new channel yes but also
no all new content will be on this
channel will I delete my old videos that
are not related to dark science nope
will I discontinue questions for
pseudoscience nope I'm still going to
debunk pseudoscience this series will be
called Dark pseudoscience what changes
will be made to this channel just the
name channel icon banner and the type of
content I'll be producing
that should about cover it if you have
any additional questions just post in
the comments and I'll do my best to
answer them this is a new and also
abrupt chapter for the channel for those
of you who've been around since 2016 or
earlier I really hope you stay the
people who just got here I know things
are different but just stick around for
a bit longer and check it out thanks for
watching